翻訳: Mika Ikeda
校正: Hiroko Kawano
みなさん こんにちは
佐藤貴志です
僕は 廃棄物最終処分場の
技術管理の仕事をしています
みなさんは 最終処分場と聞くと
どんなイメージでしょうか？
一面のゴミ
こんなイメージでしょうか？
昔はこうでしたが
現代は こうです
一体どこに
ゴミがどれだけ埋まっているのか
全然わかりませんよね
これは 環境の影響を最小限にするための
厳しい法律があって
僕たちがそれに沿って
管理しているためです
ゴミが運び込まれても
すぐに土を覆う決まりがあります
だからゴミが見えないんです
[陸上埋立]
この図は 処分場を切った断面図です
配管を通じて 酸素をゴミの中に
取り込ませることによって
自然に浄化が進んでいきます
また 雨が降って染み出てくる汚水は
コンクリートや専用のシートを使って
漏れ出さないように 守っているんです
このように 陸上でゴミを埋め立てることを
「陸上埋立」と言います
陸上埋立のほかに
「海面埋立」もあります
[海面埋立]
海に建設された処分場で
同じようにゴミを埋め立てるんです
ここ 清水にも「貝島」という
海面埋立の処分場がありますが
僕も同じタイプの処分場を担当しています
海面処分場を 陸上[処分場]と
同じ法律で管理しています
でも 地面の中では
状況が全く異なります
陸上埋立では
内部に酸素を取り込むことで
浄化が進んでいきますが
海面埋立は
ゴミが水没しているために
酸素を取り込むことができないんです
つまり 浄化のスピードが
陸上埋立より かなり遅くなります
僕は毎日の仕事の中で
海面埋立の浄化の難しさを肌で感じ
こんなことを考えるようになりました
「もし 災害でこの堤防が壊れてしまったら
浄化が完了していないゴミ[を]
未来にこのまま残してしまうのか？
何かできることはないのか？
自然をより良い形で残したい」
僕は 水没したゴミを
浄化することを決心しました
僕が大学で学んだのは 航空工学
当時は 専門は違うし 研究者でもない
実験は 仕事以外の時間で
資金はおこづかい
でも僕は 浄化をしたいという思いで
とにかく実験を開始しました
まず僕は 陸上埋立と海面埋立の
その大きな違いを考えました
それは 海面埋立は
ゴミが水没しているので
酸素を奥まで届けることが
できないということです
水没していても酸素を届けることができれば
浄化ができるかもしれない
でも 空気を送っても
泡になって浮かんでしまうので
深く浸透させ[る]ことが
できないのです
ではいったい何を使って
酸素を届ければいいのでしょうか？
僕は 発想を切り替えて ―
水に邪魔をされてダメなら
その水に酸素を溶け込ませて
届ければどうだろうと考えました
この方法には 大量のきれいな水が必要です
でも処分場の中には
すでに汚水が溜まっていて
それが流れ出さないように守っているんです
そうなれば答えはひとつ ―
溜まっている汚水をきれいにして
浄化に使えばいい
浄化に使って 水が汚れたら
またきれいにして再利用すればいい
循環型の浄化の仕組みが作れる
そう考えました
ところが ここで大きな問題がありました
それは浄化装置です
最終処分場の汚水って
とんでもないんです
硫化水素も発生していて
大の大人がひっくり返るぐらいの
すごい臭いです
こんな水をきれいに するほどの装置は
買うだけでも数千万 ―
維持費だけで
僕の給料が全部なくなります
でも これがなければ前に進めません
「よし！無いなら作ろう！」ということで
浄化装置の開発も始めました
とは言っても 敵は強敵です
僕は小さい頃 じいちゃんが
「自然からは教わることが多いんだよ」
と言っていたことを思い出して
自然の仕組みを参考にすることにしました
水を本当の意味で浄化ができるのは
やっぱり自然の力なんです
薬品を使えばすぐ効果が現れますが
最後に残るのは 薬品なんです
フィルターを使えば
それは汚れをこし取っただけです
でも 自然の力は 汚れの成分を分解して
最後に残るのは水と土なんです
先ほど この汚水を
まるで敵のように表現しましたが
そうではなく 実はこれも
微生物の分解の過程だったんです
自然の力を借りて水を浄化する装置
僕は試行錯誤を重ね 約１年
低コストな水質浄化装置
「YOU」を完成させました
この図をご覧ください
現在のYOUは６つの
処理工程を利用できます
汚水を取り込み かきまぜ
酸素を加え 生物処理１
そして生物処理２ 最後に放流です
これら全てを１つのポンプで稼働させて
同時に各ユニットに
空気を送り込む仕組みです
これが １サラリーマンでも
作ることができる
低コストの正体です
実はこれは ホームセンターで
全て材料はそろいます
心臓部は 強力な水流と
細かい気泡を使います
生物処理ユニットは
そこの水域に存在する微生物を
ユニット内に取り込んで
そして育てます
つまり そこに微生物を
持ち込んだりするようなことはしません
薬品や もともとそこにいなかった
微生物を持ち込んでしまえば
それは自然ではないからです
では 気になるその性能です
[YOUの仕様等（家庭用100V時）]
処理水のデータを見れば
効果は歴然ですが
浄化した水は
ある程度きれいな環境が必要な
ゲンゴロウなどの生物が住めるようになります
処理能力は
家庭用100Vなら30トン
この30トンを身近なものにたとえると
お風呂が150杯分です
ユニットの構成を組み替えて
200V専用機にすると
池などのもっと大きな場所を浄化できます
装置YOUはコンピュータなしで
自動運転ができる設計ですが
コンピュータを載せた場合
研究の強力なアシスタントになります
YOUは僕に代わって
24時間 実験を継続させ
データを取り続けてくれます
YOUと僕は いつも
スマートフォンでつながっていて
映像を見ながらの
リモートコントロールもできます
実は 実験をして
データを取ってくれていたのは
装置YOUなんです
僕はデータを見て 喜んでいただけ
だから 仕事をしながらでも
膨大なデータを取ることができました
こうして完成した
強力な浄化装置YOUと共に
最終処分場の土地の浄化をスタートしました
結果は 自分でもびっくり大成功
（笑）（拍手）
この成果は
最終処分場技術システム研究協会 ―
通称LSAから認めていただき
研究成果を発表させていただきました
この経験は 僕の研究の
精度を高めるきっかけとなり
LSAの先生方には たいへん感謝しています
また 僕の研究をいつも支えてくれた
住吉工業[株式会社]の中川さんには
心から感謝しています
僕の研究は
仕事のためではありません
また 利益を得るつもりもありません
僕の目的は
自然をより良い形で残すこと
僕は 装置YOUを
本当に必要とする方には
無償での技術提供を行います
もし 装置YOUが
水が汚れて困っているところで
役に立つのなら ―
もし本気で何とかしたいと
思う方たちがいるのなら
YOUの技術を提供します
もしかしたら 「何でこの人
ただで技術提供するとか言ってるの？
裏があるんじゃない？」とか （笑）
思っている方もいるかもしれませんね
でも これには僕なりの理由があるんです
今お話ししたアイデアは
今は亡き息子と一緒に過ごした
期間に考え出したものです
僕は 息子を失った悲しみを
研究に没頭することで紛らわせました
短すぎる人生を終え
彼が天国に旅立ってから
装置として形にしたものです
息子の「由悠（ゆう）」という名前には
「人のために生きることができる
優しい子になってほしい」と
願いを込めたものでした
僕は 完成した装置に
「由悠」という名前に込めた思いを
託しました
この思いを もっと生きてほしかった
彼に代わって果たしてほしい
僕はそう願って 同じ名前をつけたんです
装置が完成して
僕は２人の子どもを授かりました
これから彼らが生きる未来 ―
今は亡き息子が 生きるはずだった世界 ―
装置YOUには
未来を生きる子どもたちのために
生き続けてほしいと願っています
装置YOUの技術提供 ―
実はこの話は
具体的な要望があって
すでに動き出している話です
装置YOUは今年[2015年]
インドの子どもたちのために
生活水準の低い地域の
水質浄化に向かいます
安価に作ることができ
メンテナンスフリーであるYOUは
経済格差により手付かずの地域の
水問題解決に打ってつけです
そして国内にも
海面処分場や 池など
浄化を必要とするところは
まだまだあります
また 汚れた水は
僕たちが作ってしまうんです
僕たちが生きている限り
止めることはできません
でも 僕たちにも
できることはあるはずです
僕自身は
息子の名前を受け継いだ装置YOUと共に
人と自然界との架け橋となれるように
研究を続けていきます
今 ここに立っている僕は
みなさんから見て
特別な人間に見えますか？
研究を評価いただいて
ここTEDxに
立たせていただいたことは
僕も正直うれしいです
でも 研究を始めたときには
ただのサラリーマンだったんです
今もサラリーマンですけどね（笑）
僕が 特別な立場
特別な人間ではないからこそ
コスト面で優れた
YOUが生まれました
これからの世界を良くしたいという
気持ちと行動は
特別な人である必要はありません
ひとりひとりができることは違います
生み出すものも違います
でも 僕たちひとりひとりが
何かを良くしようと考え 行動したときに
僕たちは誰かにとって
特別な人になるんです
自分も何かやってみよう！
そんな人が１人でも増えれば
きっと状況は良くなります
そんなあなたに
YOUが寄り添い
共に生き続けることができれば
この上なく幸せです
ありがとうございました
（拍手）